And surprisingly, when  you look at both majors together,
you find that males have a much higher admissions rate than females.
I'm not making this up.
These numbers might be fake, but that specific affect
was observed at the University of California at Berkley many years ago.
But when you look at majors individually,
then you find in each major individually
the acceptance rate for females trumps
that of males, both in the first major and the second major.
Going from the individual major statistics to the total statistics,
we haven't added anything.
We just regrouped the data.
So how come, when you do this,
what looks like an admissions bias in favor of females
switches into admissions bias in favor of males?